okay yeah hello and welcome to our
broadcast Monday evening blitz it said a
good set up here on the screen
yeah it looks kind of strange let's do
some weird effects okay no it's better
okay
I hope you're all all fine yeah I've got
a couple of guys in the shed
oh there's a question can you play the
hippo set up with white or black today
you really want to get my good rating
down right no I'm not going to play it
with white I mean maybe I can go for g6
if the opponent is kind of cooperative I
mean it jobs of rating okay I'm going to
request the game we have a we have some
good good players in the game started
okay so here we got the d4 am Sherlock
you know must speak is sounding weird so
I'm going to get the bank oh that's good
at least an opening that I recently and
had a closer look at okay so this is a
normal way of playing let's see how
Sherlock plays it it's interesting for
white to play it with with Knight to a3
let's see if he goes for that I think
this is a good setup Knight to 83 I
actually have the same rating as I had
at the end of last week's session
because after that I didn't play a
single game of blitz I simply didn't
manage I had too much on my plate I had
to do some complete some things before
the weekend and the reason was that okay
I'm happy to just take everything
right yeah I just take everything now
this is usually okay for black if you
trade some minor pieces it's usually the
sign that black is fine okay
so I want to want to see here what to do
I think we nee five look at a the a pawn
yes I play this tournament on the
weekend the lippert Cup played in the
nice little town of Lima near lemon go
in the Portland OR Lipper region the
Portland is probably not exactly it
sounds like blue marlin from from Jim
cough that's probably wrong
anyway it was a nice tournament and I
did win the tournament actually so this
is the typical I've I think it's
appropriate to show it yeah I'm happy
with with the win of course I must say
that I'm not totally happy with my play
I think there were some shaky situations
that I think I'd rather not should allow
and yeah still okay I want the
tournament and I'm basically happy about
that I don't really think so
yeah you should always be in kind of
critical but if you win the event that
it isn't all that bad
so let's see here um yeah my intention
was not to take it and play with the aid
okay yeah I mean I what's the heavy
favorites there or to win that event so
I mean it's cool that it's good that I
did but it's it's kind of I'm just it
did what should be done in terms of in
terms of rating situation for for some
reason that tournament wasn't as strong
as it was
and in recent years normally they had um
yeah think you see for now I need to get
this get this going Queen takes mmm
ahead the end she takes on e7
what everybody hates him for some reason
it wasn't as strong as it was in recent
years maybe there was there was a
tournament a different tournament the
second tournament played at the same
time maybe some people were
participating there instead of the the
tournament in in Lima so who the eight
and by the way if you I mean I think I
can basically recommend to play in that
tournament I think they did a good job
organization was fine the whole yeah the
playing venue was okay everything was
was very much as it should be so if you
think about playing in that tournament I
can't recommend it yeah watch what
should you hear 9066 my background is of
course a week so let's see 95 look but
then I can take right
or not d6 95
where's he going hookup I know so
maybe probably heading towards the draw
here just am I just have to check that
I'm not doing something stupid here
threatening made here on the one after
the night move I think I go here put the
night on e6
I'm going to override your mind morning
somehow this is very loud after somehow
get the sound down a little bit yeah
okay it's not taking the draw which is I
think kind of understandable because he
has more time and he can I mean really
not was justification claimed to be
better
I can just shuffle yeah I think the
Nakamura Townsend blitz battle final
yeah that's an interesting event that
happens in roughly in roughly ten days
and I think Carlton is the favorite I
mean this is no surprise I guess that
I'm saying that but I think Callen has
proved to be very strongly in that
bullet that they play they play bullet
with one second increment and I think I
think he's he's really really strong in
that so I think see cars and as a
favorite
I still think it's a complete draw I
mean it's not much going on objectively
speaking
that's interesting that's interesting I
okay Evan to us on time ya know still a
draw I think
check the lab forfeits oh it's a dead
wrong I think what Kenny summer old
temple me here okay enter King edge 8 k
f8 and then f6 okay yeah I don't know it
was a it was a draw but I have no I have
no time to prove it okay yeah that's a
Linux penguin yeah on my top shelf I've
got it once for purchasing a certainly
dogs edition like years ago and I still
still have it
ok let's go for a new game yeah it
really shouldn't shouldn't a violent
farm why God willing us here that's
funny how do i how do i play him let's
let me think about this for just a
moment I had good positions with this
check okay so we'll see what happens him
we I had this against him in in a
regular blitz the regular blitz game and
I was kind of kind of satisfied with my
position so let's see what team comes up
here okay I mean the thing is I can go
away five now I don't know if I want to
do that I think I'll do yeah of course I
mean certainly Allah gas is what what
you might call nemesis but the thing is
in terms of scores I was on absolutely
no score and I think the last 10 games
or so I think I even know I'm on minus
one or something it's not it's not all
that bad really
yeah this is a position where white is a
little bit better I'm happy him okay
interesting a thing is should be three
now after which she would have to take
how to say I think I'll do it the knight
on d5 is a good P so why not
now where's the soap lady for Queen Anne
fire and crushed ordering us yeah I'm
not so surprised
with unconventional player I think
you're not you're not in bad shape
usually enemy of course Wesley is like
ten times better than holding us of
course okay this is a nice position the
question is what should you not be six
as possible there is also deform I think
default looks like they would move here
he cannot take sd-6 is hanging yet here
I'm taking taking here I'm taking on d6
and on c5 so I'm winning a pawn e 2 is
kind of weak though will seem okay so
probably III just keep everything
protected one problem here for black is
that the b7 pawn remains weak Bishop c6
maybe at some point okay the secret
group d3 year in this position maybe he
does
okay Queen c3 can take rookie to maybe
hmm okay
it doesn't look all that easy to be
honest here
it's it looks nice for white but still
winning is entirely different matter
preparing rook t1 or Quincy to VM I
wonder if he goes route III ever have
rook d1 maybe
yeah this one huh
but don't I take and play with you one
here no way rook takes Bishop everyone
but should have one rupee three though
okay I can do this action they would be
three I've got Bishop d7 yeah this looks
good yeah the question is can I win the
ending he's off of course very tough
defender okay so Bishop to b7 Bishop e2
c6 I am Not sure that wind is ending but
okay I do it anyway
it's very safe
I actually do when of course yeah I do
win I'm just I'm just slow here mc6 wins
I think if he takes on b7 I take and he
cannot capture because of me it is a
background made in effect and they
threaten c7 roopd hey that's over at
least I don't see a defense ok so we
found an idea c7 rook takes rook to a
drupe c7 defense ok so what to do here
what to do here if I take a 6 I'm
threatening c7 yeah that's it
neither said recent games are different
thing um I'm kind of I'm kind of doing
doing better now than I did in earlier
sessions in earlier times okay so see
seven Roxy - let's not do that
let's use the a porn I have two pawns
black resigned
thank you so um well yeah I mean I'm
doing really better in recent games
against them it's quite quite clear um
and I also changed the odd opening I
think having a bit better with with
those anyway I'm happy to have won
against him and let's go for the next
game game started again again okay so
yeah also I have a line that are
currently testing out and let's see what
he does I mean you never got anything in
in early games and let's see if he's got
something else in store now okay this is
this is something new at least let me
stem you see this is actually not a line
that is I mean it's a objectively okay
for black but it's kind of the boring
kind of position that he loves to play
so well we'll see how I fare so he
allows me to take on b3 here do I want
to do that or do I want to wait I
probably want to wait right let me wait
a little bit
if you actually changed this changes
openings this is kind of moral successor
moral successful Mia
he played something else in earlier
games against me and God
he was just worse out of the opening in
two or three games so he's now going for
a different line as I said I'm not super
happy with the position tie because this
this boring style here is just exactly
what he wants Wow well this is extremely
but he's such a boring players it's
amazing it's really amazing so he
actually wants he wants to play this
yeah I take I take e five and then he
thinks he has something in this ending
with Jesus it's crazy and maybe have
something in this ending okay I'm just
still going for it I can't but help
myself so let's see here I put a Bishop
on d5 I actually want to put a bishop on
b5 which looks looks correct
who could be hate okay my my dark
squares are bad of course
I don't like this probably not now okay
I shouldn't have gone for that it's it's
just a little bit it's a little bit it's
a bit too passive for this position
yeah that's an extremely unpleasant
position extremely unpleasant
if I get this thing to be 5 this might
be somewhat somewhat playable I still
hate it but oh he allows me to do that
really I mean okay now he now knows that
he can win on time which is of course
perfectly enough for him he never wants
to play good chess this is to totally
clear okay okay
thing is it still it's still not a total
draw and because of because of this I no
way has h5 okay
I have Bishop e2 well so maybe this is
not so bad as I first thought yeah but
it is bad it is bad still
a g5 was was bad I was really having all
abetted no I'm not a good idea
hi morning check okay
okay mmm if I take take this what's the
deal my friend Bishop e2 here 40 seconds
40 bloody seconds check
check
mmm they can he can come around right I
can't come around at okay I lose on time
anyway
now that was that was too bad that
position was too bad I mean I mean maybe
I can hold it now yeah I mean it's still
bad but he didn't prevent me from going
to be five no I don't want to analyze
his position but it was a too
inconvenient ending um I mean this line
is perfectly okay for black but I think
I probably have to do it differently
here the engine wants to do this yeah I
don't know I know I have to have to
check this line it's been it's been a
while but I understand okay this is
perfectly a Preseli I play this this
simplified position where you can
shuffle around for heaven yeah but okay
the opposite colored bishops ending was
a bit too uncomfortable so let's see who
I get ya to two games with with him in a
row bad stuff they have to check the
opening do we have something else that I
can do against them I can do a six here
that's also what I have played at half
that I have played in tournament chess
86 oops
got a request now but maybe it six is
better against him give him the IQ Pete
he usually doesn't play in those
positions well okay so I've got a
request now but no game
the thing keto defense for black on the
ROI you mean three g6 gain started yeah
I think this is a very decent Lauren
actually I have some plans with this
slide okay let's play the line again
that I used to meets mr. Wiggles Queen
to d5 what are you doing to me here with
freighter what what is the Queen doing
on h5 I'm irritated okay
yeah it's a good thing and three to six
is a good line it's okay don't mind that
line and again as I said I have some
ideas with this line so wheat free time
what's your plan here with that weird
Queen on h5 aha
I'm not going to trade let me think
the brayer or the chicken in the in the
roux yeah the brayer
I think the brayer is more it's a bit
more flexible I think if you play the
mainline sugar in I think it's okay not
the line that I play plate it's okay but
in all in all the brayer is the more
flexible line and I think therefore
should be preferred yeah I think I'm
threatening 9h 495 of those kind of
things he's not reacting
okay Knight h4 I see what does he want
what is you want to do here I don't get
it
and we're not just winning after this
what's the thing Queen moves I takes his
six apply Queen b7 and resigns why not
why am I not winning here takes and
Queen b7 black I'm winning anyway I was
really irritated here like why isn't
that winning
has anyone ever flecked omegas you know
he is not that quick
actually I mean he is quick but my
Manish I'm quicker yeah I can move
quicker but the problem is you are you
usually get there with the time
disadvantage at least I do and I mean if
I play a rook again struck against him
which is usual which is of course
totally pointless and we both get 20
seconds I will win but what's the point
usually I get down with yeah time
disadvantage and then look again through
can prove very tricky
what would I play against Carlton yeah I
know maybe work on my boxing skills and
hit him when he doesn't look what do you
want to give me me to give some advice
to say
Hakan I mean I know they certainly will
try to catch up in the opening somehow
but where exactly
Wow I haven't invested any time and I'm
not saying that I would would you have a
super great idea what you would need I
think a bit of time to to get there and
develop a clearer picture of what to do
against a certain player in some cases
my guesses weren't all that bad form
forward championship matches for example
I I
before the match of between two pallav
and in Holland I thought that the the
Lasker variation would be a good line
against Apollo and this is what what
Anand played in the final game that was
really a funny moment to see that he was
playing what I thought would be a good
idea but this is a lucky lucky hits in a
way yeah here I'm playing a line that I
have analyzed for my English series and
this is an interesting line with a with
the pawn sack where white has got a
pretty pretty nice compensation
so yeah let's do it
the the thing with with Carlton the
causal kayaking match
I think someone asked here what is a
kayaking famous for and I think the
reason why I don't really believe that
kayaking chances are all that great is
that he's from his playing style if you
want his strength and weakness profile
is in fact somewhat similar to Carson's
I mean they are both good in technical
positions they are both good in
and in defense and they yeah they kind
of usually want clarity so it's
basically kayaking it's somewhat worse
version of chasm a little bit yeah and
this is often not a great start
you have to to add nothing great to
begin with if you want to win okay let's
think a little bit about this this game
that I'm here playing so well d5 is
still does not threaten so I think I can
castle first I can take a 75 for a good
position I think yeah White has
excellent compensation here kayaking is
certainly certainly an excellent
defender probably the best in the world
but we have to really take into account
I mean John Smith is riding kayaking
strength is Putin's support this is not
not a wrong observation I think that
Russia is really heavily interested in
having him win this thing and I think
that probably the level of preparation
and what they invest for kayak ins
opening players is probably
unprecedented what's my opinion about
virtual reality for chess online I
haven't I haven't really given a thought
to that to be honest I don't know what
they do actually what they do with
virtual reality
okay c5 is interesting mmm I can also
play No
94 is also an interesting move but GSD
596 roopd 8 not totally sure c 5 looks a
bit strange even though that's probably
also compensation
okay maybe this is a little bit a little
bit slow I don't know he still cannot
play d5 easily and on d6 94 I'm also
quite happy 96 okay what's the point 95
I guess
okay I'm doing this I have to speed up
I've spent too much time admiring this
this great position and in the process
gamma clock tick down not very
surprisingly yeah three 3d and virtual
reality for chess I mean I only recently
I think yesterday I read an article that
virtual reality is the next big thing
for for pornography which is kind of
understandable if you think about it but
for chess hmm I'm not sure about it okay
so here we go
d6 I mean this is a nice position here I
maybe could have played Queen to b6 okay
this is also not bad so yeah this is the
strongest defender let's trade it off
yeah for someone who has some interest
in the bank again but this is kind of
the best position ever I mean how much
pressure do you have it's great stuff oh
really that is playable looks very shaky
hmm huh really seems to be kind of
surprised that this is a playroom
Ned still looks enormous
I think why should the exit excellent
cheese shape so what to do here I can
take a 694 is also move
yeah where's he going after this route
c6 you know I just said far too much
pressure there
time warning
I really wonder why my sound is so weird
it sounds strange black reside okay so
uh come on yeah this is this before it's
very strong for sacrifice
I'm not sure who's doing the commentary
for the World Championship match I mean
it is in New York so I'm kind of
optimistic that they get some some good
American commentators in and they have
they have some I mean I'm ICC will do
coverage of course we have a very good
team
I haven't yet heard what slots I'll get
I hope to do yeah one or two
commentary slots would be would be great
to do and I mean they certainly will
have official site I'm not sure if this
is I'm not sure how it works with the
relay I think they they have the moves
but or you can get the moves but don't
they don't have pictures I think they
want to do pay-per-view for the for the
for the video so yeah okay I'm back end
back to 2500 or two so I only lost the
booty gas game the second oldest game I
hadn't lost the first one again Sherlock
of course okay King Robert DeNiro at
Andrew Dice Clay for commentary New York
that sounds like a fun idea you know
especially Andrew Dice Clay is he's so
um is he still doing comedy I don't know
I really since Ford Fairlane I didn't
really follow it follow him
so this is actually the g6 line that
earlier missile garcia asked about it's
the same line that I had on the board
against them against Yaakov anko in the
inverse West at the stream last week you
know or the one before that
it was very memorable one I beat Jack
Evancho twice with exactly this
variation so interesting I get it get it
again yeah yeah let's see what white is
doing now
so this is I think quite nice that I
slowed him down a little bit there on
this side of the board of course this
kind of play as well known from the
Kings in Ian the bionet attack I'm still
quite happy here I think okay what to do
I can go I think I'll go g5 actually
yeah my idea here was to check with the
night and then oops take with the night
and play for GT for at night to deform
hmm we'll see I think it's interesting
my bishop on g7 of course is kind of
rotten but you cannot have it all hmm
this should be screaming
hmm interesting
he wants to go to you for quite clearly
um okay I wonder have Knight g4 is an
option here
rabid okay I think ultimately I need
this activity
yeah I'm definitely getting activity but
I also have tons of weaknesses so here
night aged 5 to f4 was my idea I just
wonder if he goes G 3 d 4 is hanging a
night H 5 is probably just going G 3 but
I still probably have to do it I have to
keep the form the night on H 5 meaning
is of course a problem who do I get that
activated I don't know I'm thinking
queen is 7 Queen e2 here 5 Wow
really see six let's just blast this
open and see what happens
he takes it okay but their work is
hanging
g5 is also hanging
have some have some have some big issues
in Wow Wow what is what what is what
what what went wrong yeah I'm not quite
sure really
this position is just bad it's just the
only way to describe it it's just a bad
position
neither five is pretty pretty awful mm
maybe 94 - hang on what the heck was
that
well Knight g5 something that that
that's kind of dicey if I get 95 in
maybe maybe objectively it's it's
terrible but maybe I have some chances
with 95 time warning he takes it okay
well he's not threatening to take any of
the rooks
as I have the Queen the Queen is hanging
so let's do this he might just take the
knight actually and then move the Queen
no Queen d5 stuff like that yeah yeah I
am he's playing as well
mm-hmm yeah very good game by white I
think I probably shouldn't have played
this g4 justness I think I'm okay up to
this point it would be a bit strange if
I wasn't 93 wins as well 996 okay I
wanted to go Bishop T forever I'm
getting in the 40s only black resigns
now I think I think I probably should
have wait to play em should shut them
wait to played you for him I have to
play differently I think I should be
okay in this position it would be
strange if I wasn't the engine wants to
double on their front gives me some
advantage I should be at least okay no
he actually can take this refutes the
white white play completely anyway I
didn't I didn't play that one good okay
next game which is probably the final
one for this session let's see what we
get game started not playing Alex with
black okay Alex this is a teammate of
mine let's go for the okay let's let's
play add ruffian and play the Slav
exchange so let's see what he is up to
in the Slav exchange
hmm he doesn't want to play for a draw
it seems okay we'll see what happens I
know there is no psychological thing
going on here with 2500 you just said
you sometimes just you don't play every
game well him just what it is and I
think my opponent played a good game the
game before I mean I had chances but you
always have them yeah
it's nothing it's just what it is they
they the other guys can play chess as
well okay so here he is really doing
something him and see I'm going to
prepare 5 him so f5 you really go G for
them he might do it huh
it's an interesting question if it goes
G for here or not
I have home ok takes this I think I'm
going to take with the Queen so that G
for Bishop g6 is possible that's
interesting I can take with the pawn or
with the rook it both makes some sense
to be honest I go for that it's it's it
makes before um I have before I'm
controlling before battle
I think the the Slav exchange is
probably more boring than the French
exchange but it's only a matter of
attitude I have actually I have a
fantastic score with the Slav exchange
with both colors and I think you just
have to yeah and one part say ok it's it
is boring ok but so are many other
things and you just have to have to
start to fight and then then it's ok it
doesn't really matter how boring the
opening is ok Knights you form
yeah I can can you just not really right
bishop a1 I'm taking so what's that's
the deal here I can take on b2 here so I
can cover I mean I can cover this ask
him about a move yeah I would like to go
96 and and Sonia I have this also Bishop
age 4 but it doesn't really do all that
much yeah I think I could be fine as the
question is I mean at some point I can
play Knight be to Bishop III not sure if
the point is now probably not
Bishop before maybe
I don't know time is ticking down a bit
okay
since I cannot take
so 93 he will take a couple of times
then take III hmm
kind of shame that this works maybe he
can take a couple of times and play
Bishop c5 rook c5 maybe check
i-it's not a ticking d5 uh-huh
oh that's nicely done I'm morning I
didn't I didn't really see that they did
a good job they're from this absolutely
crappy position getting here I mean what
white had really bad position and he
managed to get to get to this really
good job
clap now I can take it I didn't oh
that's lucky that's lucky and queens and
I should have trade at home check
yes he's six wins
I mean Chrissy doing here it gets weird
I get to the five I'm okay okay so he's
completely screwing this up from from a
win to this my suits on not not
completely unfortunately let me think
about it I don't have time him age 65
maybe
bloody time
check the bloody frickin time draw
offered of course not
I've got four seconds and I cannot lose
and now we get the drawn bloody draw now
I should windows are falling at the end
right okay the whole game was weird yeah
that was really weird
I mean I totally screwed this up like
right here I mean around here should be
in really good shape but I didn't do
this correctly this is this is kind of
annoying I mean this must be
strategically good for black with this
with a strange bishop on d2 and then
then he played that really well
defending this very well and they
provide probably I'm very sure that the
computer will find something but that
doesn't really matter it was a really
well conducted defense Jim and I had 97
but of course I mean I I just blinded
this in one movie and this was the main
thing but even here I'm still in trouble
and here the end game is the winner 20
seconds it's bad I
should-should should win this I can
probably our tempo him right like this
this this this how to do that this
should be seven and now I've got Bishop
f6 okay okay okay
yeah this is the position I can go to a3
or to f6 okay guys I didn't really did
look at the chat all that much I was
more focused on playing it was was a
tough session and so we have any things
is there anything that I should check
with my favorite chest book with a
hyperbolic mega awesome title I don't
know if there's really such a such a
book I mean if you want my opinion on a
good book which will be the crap title
yeah you can take a pump up your writing
by excellent Smith that's a really good
book and it has the the absolutely
weirdest title how can you call a book
pump up your rating is really weird so
yeah it's a good book but it has a weird
title okay I hope you guys enjoyed the
stream I think I have to I mean I played
exactly zero glitz games between the two
thousand between the two sessions and it
showed a little bit so I hope that we'll
get get better till next week yeah
thanks for watching I'll be back next
Monday bye bye